cada día derriban un edificio dañado
para poder construir uno nuevo sobre él
estos bloques de apartamentos están
apareciendo por todo a Mario Paul
Y esta es la otra cara de la ciudad la
parte de los ucranianos que decidieron
quedarse han sobrevivido pero sus casas
aparecen a punto de derrumbarse
Pero Jesús vengo aquí todos los días no
tengo otra cosa que hacer me volvería
loca Si me quedaré en casa todo el día
vivo aquí desde 1963 con los cuatro del
mundo Quiero hablar con la gente
gente como Valery lana han pasado juntos
los peores momentos de sus vidas Durante
los bombardeos en este edificio
mi mujer y yo solíamos dormir aquí
bebíamos agua de la calefacción central
la hervíamos se lo imagina
pero su Refugio se convirtió en objetivo
el día que los combatientes ucranianos
se escondieron allí un bombardeo provocó
un incendio en el que la madre de Valery
y otros vecinos ancianos murieron
cuando salimos del sótano estaba
Ardiendo Cuando llegamos al segundo piso
hacía demasiado calor Incluso en el
sótano la temperatura alcanzaba los 47
grados los sacamos en bolsas de plástico
sus restos y huesos pero fueron
enterrados correctamente en el
cementerio enterré a mi madre
de vuelta a su propio barrio Valeria
encontró su casa dañada Él y su mujer no
Tienen calefacción la temperatura es de
6 grados Celsius no tienen agua
No tenemos ropa limpia no podemos
ducharnos desde septiembre
y eso no es lo que más les duele no he
hablado con mi hijo porque no tengo
electricidad
no sé si podremos sobrevivir
para los rusos Mario Paul ya es suya
aunque los combates podrían volver algún
día a la ciudad ya que Ucrania ha
prometido reconquistarla